vampires
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right last time we had a
demonstration on which Asian accent was
the most romantic yeah man we found out
as Vietnamese
now we need to figure out which accent
is the most intimidating
intimidating like it makes you scared I
think Vietnamese and the way we're gonna
find that is by reading a popular uh
scene from Taken oh [__] is it is it the
scene
take it away Steve wait what do we meet
yeah
let's read this right just read it
normally however you want
I don't know who you are
I don't know what you want if you're
looking for ransom I can tell you I
don't have money but what I do if it's
very particular set of skills skills I
have acquired over a very long career
skills that make me a nightmare for
people like you if you let my daughter
go now
that'll be the end of it
I will not look for you I will not
pursue you but if you don't I will look
for you I will find you and I will kill
you
oh he's back it's all where they put the
emphasis
we still need you
all right so you guys know that scene
from Taken where Liam Neeson's on the
phone and he's uh his daughter just got
kidnapped yeah and he's uh basically
trying to instill fear yeah to the
nerves of this guy in the other line
yeah have you seen it recently good luck
that's all he says good luck have you
seen that scene in recently I haven't
seen a recently why I saw it recently
and I was like get the [__] out of here
really I used to love that the movie I
still love that it doesn't work now to
me I go
well why you know why is because he
wasn't German enough oh
[Laughter]
dude this is hard do it do it do it
I gotta do that to set the tone like
sometimes it's hard that's his warm-up
throw your voice
I don't know who you are
I don't know what you want
if you're looking for ransom
I can tell you I do not have money
but what I do have
is a very particular set of skills
skills I've acquired over a very long
career since death is bad
I'm losing it
housing you're channeling like a German
Richard Nixon or something yeah it was
kind of it was kind of weird
um where was I let's go
but what I do have
as a very particular set of skills
saying particularly weird German
villains never scare me though even
they're they're supposed to what about
the gun not Hitler not Hitler I mean
like the [__] in uh the glorious
bastards in glorious back yeah but like
is my German accent too cartoonish what
about the red so it sounds too Indian it
does sound Indian say the last few lines
maximum intimidation
get cold and dark if you let my daughter
go now that's villainy that's villainy
Pizza under it that's good oh yeah I
would not look for you nah that was bad
the nasally helped I like how you're
you're doing Hitler mustache yeah yeah
no no it just helps no you're doing him
yeah it just helps me it's Hitler
mustache I will not pursue you no that's
bad I will not pursue you
that was Alabama
I don't know what I'm saying anymore
but if you don't I will look for you I
will find you
and I will kill you oh that last part I
give that I give that a 4 out of ten you
landed it I got a four out ten last time
uh you did Korean right for the for the
romantic thing you did Korean and then
you did Chinese oh did I yeah your
Korean is pretty good that in Korean
would be pretty good Mark's Korean is
best when he says the word matapaka
you can ad-lib too I don't think so dude
Liam Lisa did ad-lib dude
hahaha
this guy's a good actor I
don't know who you are
I
don't know what you want
but if you're it what the [__] is going
on
it's hard to do it again
you're trying to be in like two
different mindsets you know when you
have like the accent you already have a
character but then now your character is
changing to this person you're like what
is this yeah what are you doing right
now Korean yeah I don't know Bart over
prepared though
if you're looking for ransom
that I don't have any money okay
I have a choir over like a pretty long
time in my careers
[Laughter]
for people like you
know like let boo scare you
if you if you let my daughter go now
that'll be the end of this okay and
peace happy I love you whatever I would
not looking for you I would not pursue
you like look at you through my rear
view mirror or anything like that but if
you don't that I will look for you and I
will literally like find you on a GPS a
[__] Google trans
satellite image GPA all that crazy [__]
I have everything because I'm Korean I
want everything and then I think at the
end uh after I schedule a live then I'm
gonna suck your blood and maybe kill you
after about I don't know I haven't
decided thank you
whatever
[Laughter]
that's the funny thing about the scene
the scene is so long why is it so long
he's on the phone and you're just like
all right bro I'm not buying this wait
is he talking to an Asian guy no I'm
talking about he's like good yeah yeah
he's a white dude yeah and the guy's on
the phone like listening to him I forgot
albanians exist
so we're trying to see who the scariest
Asian accents are I just did like a
[__] Gravelly dude could it be
we didn't get Jeff y's last time you
need a samurai sword no I'll show you oh
Yakuza Japanese oh yeah cool
see that's his
I don't know what do you want can't give
Joe a massage in the back yeah yeah yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
but what I do have are very particular
set of skills
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
but if you don't
I will look for you I will look fine to
you and I will kill you kill you
that's good
the guy was my Uber driver one time
that's very good thank you thank you
that's good they ain't got no l it's
like ours
[Applause]
yeah I will kill you kill you when it
starts with the r it turns into a l when
the word starts with the r it turns into
a l but then when it ends with the r
turns into an L
yeah
what's that oh
reality show so the L turns into R can
you take that dialogue
and dance it
[Laughter]
you're asking for the worst part of the
video dude yeah are you sure
I'll back you up but now it's getting
worse I mean is that possible is that
something that dancers can do
come on please no my career is like
still in the middle of it like I'm in
the middle of my story arc you don't
think maybe it's like at a tail end when
I'm exiting type thing all right last
time freaking uh canned Vietnamese been
at the top spot how about we compare
Vietnamese
is also the most intimidating as it is
the most romantic it is my money's on
Japanese was kind of scary Japanese is
good Japanese was pretty scary I try to
do gangster but then I don't think I did
a good job I like how you guys are by
the way taking a white roll and turning
it into a bunch of eggs get used to it
brother because it's gonna happen yeah I
guess I will I'm taking your job I will
also you got this guy doing [__]
German this guy doing Korean he's not
Korean the Japanese guy is doing
Japanese I am 3 23 and me said he's a
couple Korean percent so he could do it
okay oh nice I gotta practice my German
accent more I haven't done that in a
while I um I'll do he's in the Squadron
I do Vietnamese Uncle there's different
kinds of people do the most intimidating
one yeah wait that means he needs this
and timing oh you hold on hold on you
gotta have your uncle [__] okay sit man
oh [__]
yeah it looks like Vietnamese
[Laughter]
I don't know how to be the drunk man
back you up man wrong man you got to be
his height man peace hey you don't worry
man you don't worry me while he's
getting a tattoo
ready
I don't know who you are oh man I don't
know what you want oh God damn
if you're a tattoo for some Ransom
that's money I can tell you I don't have
the money
no money man this guy in the broke man
I only have children what but what do I
have
a very particular set skill [__]
Talent man skilled to pay the bill
are quite over the very long career hey
old man
skill that making me a nightmare like
people like you scary
[Laughter]
if you let my daughter go
maybe I give you money maybe maybe but
maybe but my daughter had to be not a
hoe okay make sure she's still the
Virgin don't put it in the hall that'll
be the end of it
I'll not look for you I will not pursue
you I will not do your nail
I will look for you and I will find you
and I will kill you
and eat your dog
that's good plastic that's good that's a
classic Ender
I think can't wins again can is the
Undisputed uh action King no doubt no no
that sounds pretty gangster yeah
also I love the little racism at the end
perfect yeah yeah it's a crowd pleaser
right so it's real big it's good he
could have said the type of dog could
have said like eat your beagle but I
liked what he did I liked it give me my
goal man
so yeah I think there might be something
that's not here that I wish we had like
Indian Filipino and Indian
people you're like but he doesn't do it
he does Filipino says his dad or make
Steve do Filipino all right I'll try to
do it
do it I want you to do it
come on
[Laughter]
they always have this like lips thing
they're just upset and then you start
with going
huh
I don't know who you are
I don't know what you want
but if you're looking for ransom
I can tell you I don't have money but
what I do have
it's a very particular set of skills
skills I have acquired
over a very long career
skills that make me a nightmare for
people like you
if you let my daughter go
that will be the end of it
I will not look for you
I will not pursue you
but if you don't I will look for you
I will find you
and I will kill you
that that's it
that's very scary too
that's scary because it's ugly that's
kind of scary
it's definitely more on the funny side
I don't know man he's a nurse that's
gonna kill you when he did this with
when he did the lip thing I was like oh
[__] it's hard to be intimidating I
think Filipino Wise It's because it's
comical I also think we're culturally uh
trained to think that Japanese is like a
more Thug you know like voice well
because they'll kill themselves too oh
[__] they already don't give up they'll
stab both ways they're like what the
[__] both ways they go pissed
they'll stab both I mean that's why we
have a population problem
[Music]
thank you